hi guys i'm lauren zima from
Entertainment Tonight here at the craft
services on the shark tank set we have
talked to every single shark about
everything they love to eat and look at
this we're here when they're celebrating
winning their Emmy they got some
cupcakes so what are the Sharks eat who
eats the most who's the hungriest
thirstiest shark we're about to find out
[Music]
we have amazing craft services honestly
I never get to eat or come over here I
mean it's like three seconds between
each entrepreneur truthfully but when I
have looked around I have noticed they
have will they cook things like burritos
and in the morning there's eggs sausage
patties and stuff and then there's a
whole variety oh you have a cheese board
here does she work there seaweed wrap
it's a little strange for me I look at
this stuff you know a little eclectic
I'm into the whole idea of health so
what I try and do is keep my Adonis
figure in shape so celery stick maybe
you know maybe a slice of apple or
something well he must have an
investment in celery sticks cooler than
that I don't know what he's talking
about the way the Keven is shaped stays
around the donut area a deal will run
anywhere from 25 minutes to an hour
right and then they have to reset up so
we've got like six seven minutes to kill
and so 10 times a day we're walking back
here shoving food and sometimes we'll
have a deal and then we'll come and
shove more food have a deal for more
food then we'll go to lunch then we'll
shove more food what is the healthy
snack that gets you through the day well
this is healthy cookies I bring them on
the set and Robert you never stop
snacking when he saw vodka by the time
I'm trying I'm trying to do the no sugar
no carb bang its cupcake yeah yeah it's
a bit of a nightmare but you know when
you're on TV I got to watch for that
week I am NOT good normally with Barbara
it's different you know she's very lean
and mean and there's a reason a lot of
people don't know this about Barbara the
only reason she gets here on time is I
bought her a broom so you know she only
eats from the
aldrin at night which she's there with
the other witches now you come up with
the stuff it's all true that's the thing
I'm just telling the truth
who is the hungriest shark who snacks
the most Robert Robert but I think he
snacks healthy let's talk about Robert
he'd stuff his face with all of this
stuff like you can see him hiding in the
corner with about 20 of these little
things like a gerbil eating them just
terrible really really bad he eats my
food I mean he'll be eating his food
he'll take my food something will fall
on the ground Robert will pick it up and
eat it and Mark Cuban he just can't stay
away from the craft table and plus when
they're giving his food products he
steals mine I can't even try the samples
you just chose everything down that's in
front of him and then war do you guys
know each other well enough that you
know each other's favorite foods at this
point he eats everything and so I mean
everything you know just he'll eat a
candle that's a real problem mark
doesn't eat anything with dairy in it
because if he does we all suffer from it
up there because he's very intolerant so
how do you loves you but I gotta tell
you your other sharks might not love you
as much because what the other one said
is that you snack the most you eat the
most and that you have the worst sweet
tooth are these statements trip you can
tell when we start shooting early in the
season because my face is finished by
the time you'll know which episode is
the last one to shut the deals the last
that we shop because my face is like are
you the fittest shark I would probably
have to say yes who's the fittest shark
who's in the best shape me yes you know
I don't want to boast or anything but
you know it's about the balance of
exercise and eating right I am in the
best shape of all the shark although
mark has lost a lot of weight this year
you're looking fit what's the secret
have you got back off services well they
even if he's snacks
[Music]
you
[Music]